Wow Wow something that was beautiful
that was good beautiful yes ha ha
future builder future builder
Oh
hmm
hmm
okay
hmm
yes sir
Oh
[Music]
Oh
yes sir
yes sir
is that how things normally start you
sit down with someone
No
feel really comfortable
with you
feel very tapped in that's all that is
this is the person sometimes stay silent
and then you go after a period of
just looking at each other and smiling
serious laughing breath you go yes sir
and then they say something
well
I just see you take the lead a lot in
general
terms of the flow of things
yeah
I'm also very downto have other people
take the lead of the flow when it's
going and like a really good trajectory
for beautiful play between humans and
throughout time I'm like great
so when you hold space sometimes it's
like
no silence and just like a spirit to
spirit meeting beforehand sometimes
there's none of that sometimes there is
that
sometimes the person me right away just
say something about what they want to
talk about sometimes it may take a
really long time before something said
hmm is that about because you do the
space holding
yeah
hmm
why are we here
I've been asking myself that a question
for a long time now
why are we here that one yeah so I took
it to the abstract one which I love that
question why humans are here on the
planet but why you and I are sitting
here in space that's being held by you
it's exploration exploration
of a non-repetitive
states of consciousness of
very unique deep explorations of the
psyche of the spirit
but you're already good aren't you no I
don't know myself
linked anyone that says that they know
themselves
it's hard to say that one knows
themselves fully
and have a bunch of things especially
from like when you're born into the
world and even before that all the
ancestral stuff that happens with your
parents and their parents and their
parents through you and then when you're
born you don't even know anything that
really happened to you until you were a
couple years old so a lot of things got
laid into me that I'm not that aware of
so we could potentially see what what's
there
I like being closer to your eyes
go back
you could feel like a little kid
sometimes I love it kind of reminds me
of Alexia the little spirit Kid
I'm gray
just felt a lot of like
with
sadness about being a child and just
missing it
and just a lot about the children
growing up today what they're
experiencing
feels really nice to see it a moat like
that
feels like a gift
we move really fast on the show it's not
really space for this
that's what's nice when there is space
for it
[Music]
No
Allen shotgun cry yes
I love these feelings
yeah thank you they're unique they're
novel they're non-repetitive
when does your spirit get so
moved by an emotion like that
rarely
yes
we're sitting here feeling together yeah
twenty-six-year-old hair you grown
leaders yeah
humans
feeling together such a beautiful thing
slowing down enough in the craziness of
the economic machinery to just be
yeah
thanks for leading the way with emoting
today
I felt a lot even right after that
I don't want to share don't that I want
to share oh that you want yeah please
I love seeing you like this I was
feeling it
the space for it
yes yeah
what I felt
that
the innocence
you are innocent the innocence of
spirits on the first broadened
how
unready some parents are and how
aspects of our society
don't necessarily always enable the
young innocent spirit to fully realize
itself
care so much about that
the forgetting
it's been a big fall from grace
forgetting that we come from creation
from mother from spirit from nature
that's what they say
and feeling it is
does feel that way
I'm here brother I love you
I love you too
Allen I've never seen you like this
I don't think I felt it so much before
because I'm so frequently just
intellectualizing about the subject
yeah I'm sure that's a frequent thing
that over here yeah I'm always thinking
about it but I haven't felt it so deeply
if people are willing to go there yes
yeah
ah
you serious twenty-six-year-old Alan
sake on commanding leader just breaking
down here yeah out of love
yeah so in being totally happy with that
yes being with it yeah
and we
thanks Rob Thanks
and what is it that is holding back our
leaders of
the world from doing this
well
what will people think
what will people think of us
the first thing that came up is the fear
of being perceived as weak that's the
first thing that I that I feel that many
people that we've built a society a bond
that that's the reason why we won't
share these vulnerable beautiful moments
it's uh can you imagine the presidents
of countries sitting here like this and
just like to like I'm having emotional
deep depths exploring them like that
about the families about their
upbringing about children
that's the room that's what mother would
want us to to be harmoniously
unconsciously living with each other and
the nature that we resided
in yes yeah like
how do you feel
I feel like I'm just watching like Blake
to the Watchi like what is going on damn
kind of humbling
that's how I feel about our world too
just
humble little spirit coming through
interest
just feeling and watching
the world
but why could you feel so much without
even being on anything without even
being on drugs like yeah that's a great
question it's so such an important one
like not everyone knows that this level
of love is like available per scene
and doesn't require mind-altering
substances exogenously all within our
ability to get to these levels of love
and it's so profound
so unexplored
there was a really good way of putting
it recently which was that
you can go to any corner in Metropolis
and order food in from any ethnicity in
any way or style that you want
but why for something as
Oh G has so baked into our human
evolution the social-emotional
relationships between each other
is there no ubiquity and metropolis for
you to just go and say hey I'd like to
order some Blanc and then with this
specific style from this specific
ethnicity etc and be able to just sit
down and be with someone that can help
you with that social emotional aspect
or ultimately yourself yeah
a holding space for ourselves yeah
forgetting about that is sad
but it's a challenge
so I like both feel really like sad
about us forgetting about the importance
of that
but I also feel like rise up to the
challenge that is why there is the
challenge because it's supposed to be
hard
we came to forget and play in the mud
Andrey remember
that's what they say and that's what it
feels like
totally what it feels like
where does one even start with thinking
about their ancestors and what they
experienced and what you then carry and
also what you picked up from your first
couple months and years of life where
does one even start to say that that I'm
what I am now and that's that's that and
I will I will shield off everything and
carry myself this way that's like
forgetting so much of the point of life
to bring those walls down to remember
how complex who you are actually is
and to be able to be willing to dive
into that yourself there's sincere deep
self work and also to have the space for
bringing other people into that yes
sharing it feeling together yes I like
what you said about yourself because
that's the most important relationship
and that's who you got to be truthful
with them no matter what then at first
there's a skillfulness to who do I want
to share my heart with right like when I
started opening to my grief and stuff
then it was like okay hang on some
friends maybe some family I want to
share to my coach probably not you know
it says there's a skillfulness but with
yourself we can become more truthful in
this world
we can build more clarity
we can unravel our parts we can
undistorted
we can integrate our pieces
yeah I love it over a little bit who
rule it's so well said
there's a
something that you mentioned I thinks so
important is remembering that as we
start on distorting this love that how
we decide to share with who we decide to
share how we decide to share it's very
important all it takes sometimes is one
person to say all of that's so lame
and then you from your perspective of
wanting to feel and share and open up
can just close you back up yeah when the
opposite is also true that you can share
and then someone can validate validate
yeah and then you're forever he'll like
transform the opposite of trauma you
know so
but it all starts with self sensitivity
yes
you talk about nature you know being
sensitive to life we have and we are a
piece of life so building sensitivity to
ourselves is the spiritual path
that building sensitivity through
ourselves as the spiritual path yes
getting to know ourselves no matter what
that looks like
doesn't matter if it looks insane if
we're insane we I mean insanity is
enlightenment but we need to get it out
under the light to be witnessed and
integrated and understood so then we're
a walking integrated force of nature
I'm just feeling it again yeah
yes you're doing that very well tonight
it's a sensitivity to both how much I
want to more deeply go into these spaces
help others go more deeply into these
spaces their sensitivity
and just make it so that the the streets
of our world are filled with more of
these sensitive es spiritual beings yes
yes
now one might wonder what if I'm
practicing becoming sappy what if and
I'm becoming that way by feeling this is
very good point yeah
and my experience is that's not the case
it can be if you actually do that if you
start saying hey this is this feels
really healing I'm gonna try to grieve a
lot then yeah but if you're just aware
of your body of yourself and within the
flow of your life in your reflection
your journaling these things do arise
then you're processing you're shedding
you're integrating and you're becoming a
pure less distorted vessel for us
then you can show up more cleanly more
clearly for others most of the
quote-unquote a halt a holes that we
encounter in our lives that get under
our skin
they're just in pain and so when we get
to know and be okay with and feel and
process our pain we can show up
differently and our footprint
quote-unquote becomes greener MC I just
like had to hug myself because that I
was so you know that was so warm and
yeah but I hear that
damned greener essence are as we move
through the world
more positive the aura is more abundance
it's more sensitive and the people that
aren't feeling that usually that haven't
dived into those depths are like you
said in some sort of a pain or some sort
of a trauma or have never even went
there and know that that even exists and
then just live on the surface of emotion
instead of in the depths of emotion and
I think the point you made about
sappiness is really important because
you can be on either side of this deep
end let's say you can either be on the
side of where you've never ever ever
experienced any of the deep vulnerable
beautiful emotions and tapped into what
your ancestors have felt tapped into
what you yourself have felt when you
were young tapped into any of those
traumas or any of the
pains
but you can also be on the other side
which is where you just constantly live
in that all the time
yes it's a skillfulness to it
so there's a skillfulness in both
diving really deep into those and then
coming back with like things that you've
learned mm-hmm and then there's also the
skillfulness of knowing how to share and
who to share with how to hold space yes
and so I've told people like step one
like I shared is knowing our truth being
honest with number one like that
truthful relationship with yourself
that's step one you know so like
journaling and getting good at
encapsulating your heart you know if I
meet a girl that I like
maybe I journal and I get really clear
and sometimes it might be really like
soft and innocent like I hope we can be
friends like oh like that captures
literally like how I'm feeling like I
just feel like that child and then
that's step one like capture your heart
be truthful with yourself know your step
two is then you can play with it to meet
the situation maybe I'll send off a text
with exactly that or maybe I'll alter it
by sensing into it there's a
skillfulness maybe this person hasn't
done a lot of this sort of work and so
it won't land in a healthy way
that's so so true
yeah when when if if one has done a good
amount of the work and then someone else
has not that the messaging can be
lost
I want to even say even before know
thyself or maybe together with know
thyself as the most important things is
also just know the true essence an
embodiment of how beautiful it is to
even be alive to be here in creation
itself is enough and with that know
yourself mmm it's like those two
principles like roaring together
everyone was carrying those two
principles whoa yeah yeah and like you
said yeah craft the craft of the of the
message may be altered due to the
how many accolades the person has from
going deep into their own selves as well
as other people
Wow
or you mean here to do this more
we need to do this more we need to share
this more need to make this cool me to
make this mainstream yes to talk about
this wisdom with influencers yeah
that can you imagine if we had some of
the influencers sitting
here to unpack the the depths with how
cool could they make it really quickly
it's also fun doing it at the grassroots
level - yes yeah
but we need to make it we need to win
the wisdom race did the amount of
technologies that have the capacity that
have been democratized that have the
capacity to be malevolent we have to
level up our wisdom really fast and so
by making things mainstream like holding
space we can level up our wisdom faster
yes but what influencers want to do this
what influencers want to talk about it
I've been thinking about that
we'll take a little bit of time too
because if you're already killing the
game as your stick
well what game were you really killing
is another question what game are you
succeeding at you're succeeding at that
surface game but have you succeeded at
the depths game
because if we show that there's a whole
nother game that hasn't been explored
that you're not the master at yet it can
maybe incentivize people but to go
maskers if people have mastered
something then why do that nobody likes
becoming the the student again only if
you're inspired yeah and also just that
how how boring does it become if if you
embody that mentality of never wanting
to become the student again to
constantly be a student of life has such
a
deep meaningful fulfilling purpose and
so if you mare if you ever just say I've
already mastered and I'm just gonna for
the next 60 years just chill it's like
mmm you know there's more there's more
things to master don't you want to go
and explore those social emotional
intelligence there's nothing more epic
than a path of accelerated healing and
growth
yeah
and that was all said
nothing more epic than a path
accelerated healing and growth
we can wreak this popular
if ever then I guess I guess today
things are shifting there
and we haven't even gotten into that was
just one little piece of it it was just
being here and and just being with each
other feeling together and then finally
we got something within me about feeling
the little spirits that are coming
through the world and then being able to
figure themselves out that that brought
forth what it did for us and that was
just that that wasn't even going deep
into oh my are unlimited were unlimited
who our parents are who their parents
are who we are how they influenced us
who we were when we were just born into
the world where we were living at the
time what was our birthplace where was
it what did we absorb when we were there
well this is the mind I people think of
a mind as some abstract like thinking
thing but I see it as this web of like
real parts there are these like chords
in energetic dynamics and they're an
ecosystem we live in and so we can
garden it
you can nourish it we can discern within
our garden and cut some weeds yeah
now that wasn't that was a great one
that's so okay let's let's feel that
together do we really just have
thousands of flowers in our garden and
that's it
hmm probably not we probably have some
weeds in our garden we probably have
some soil that hasn't been getting much
water or attention recently
we probably have some
sometimes we may only have just patches
of the same flower
we haven't diversified our garden with
other flowers yeah
I like this one this is a good one
it's a good one for the synthesis I'll
remember that one
it has a lot to do with that
with having the right nutrients and then
being able to flower really good fruits
has so much to do it I love that
let's make this cool
and let's make it easy
so it can be as easy as identifying
maybe five people that you think could
be a good fit for this type of a thing
in your
network and then
and then asking them to do it
and being really vulnerable about asking
them to do it maybe you say that you
want to share something maybe you say
that I want to hold space for you to
want to share something or just see what
emerges but
and you can start really simple when you
do get there of talking about people's
childhood or people's relationship with
their parents or who they are you know
who are you really what is your purpose
here and that in itself can open up like
oh oh my gosh why haven't I answer that
question to myself in the last month six
months year or two years ten years ever
and that can open up so much good stuff
so it's popularized that and then also
get it more
influencers start hearing these things
more these leaders around the world
start hearing holding space why is that
so cool why have I haven't why haven't I
heard of it oh I'm gonna bomb in a whole
space and I'm gonna put it on my social
platforms I want to do it too
yeah I want to feel that are they all
they're all raving about feeling they're
not even using any drugs I want to feel
like that - they look blissed-out and
loving
hmm
and they also can channel all sorts of
other energies radiantly
because they've cleaned out the muck
yes
we become a better channel for our own
purposes when we clear out the muck and
also we can then become a channel for so
many other mmm a superconductor
superconductor there's like every
setting is an energetic equation and the
energy is shared and so if you're clear
like it gets interesting
you have the capacity if you're clear to
deal with the energy equation in ways
that are fluid in the dynamic in
balancing balancing
balancing the energy versus when you
have muck it's almost as though whatever
is happening in the energy equation that
first of all you're not really
perceiving the energy equation yeah as
you have muck
and next is there's really it's really
hard for you to engage with energy your
agent it can take you out can if you
have triggers if you have triggers he's
gone it's over compromise you're
compromised immediately something
happens you get triggered and you're not
even in control you're behaving yeah
you're good
it's only coming out of me because
you've practiced it so much and you're
here with me sharing the feeling and I
think we're able to co-create some cool
takes on on this yeah
it's also good for the science geeks
that humans together are an energy
equation and you have to be cleared of
the muck within yourself to be able to
engage with the energy equation yes I
like that it's really good yes
maybe you can think of you could maybe
even think of if a person is a
you can think of a variable the person
is a variable in the equation and if the
variable has a lot of other complicated
arithmetic around it it's going to be
really hard to engage with the mm energy
of the of the group but if your variable
is very clean the arithmetic is very
clean it's easier to
engage with the yes equation yes you can
kind of see people carrying a lot of our
stick around they're variable and versus
being completely clear and clean right
and then what you get to do is live in
epic life because you're gonna be
putting on and taking off a lot of
costumes and that's fun ooh while
knowing that their costumes and that's
why we're here and we're here to come
play in that way yeah
yeah
and those those costumes are
there's some of the most fun ways to
play and another think easy way to for
people to remember is that when when you
when you when you use when you talk to
someone that were such mirroring
creatures that we like to mirror and so
if you have a big wardrobe of costumes
you can more easily mirror people and
build rapport and emotional connection
with them yes if we have just the small
little closet that only has one or two
costumes there's so many costume
possibilities and it's harder for us to
connect to people there's something
exciting about becoming decorated
becoming a decorated king or queen of
yourself integrating in exchanging in
relationship with people and just
holding all the energies and then you
become a decorated piece of life a
nuanced piece of life and you have a
repertoire and you become a rainbow
Oh
okay we are these we are these avatars
we come through spirit into this world
to play to learn in the school of life
and when we do things like decorate our
avatar with more of color names--
learning we've learned how to put on
different costumes we've learned certain
accolades that we can apply in our life
and it becomes easier for us to engage
with other spirits that are in their
costumes no matter what costume they're
wearing no matter what accolades they
have if we've at least had training open
honest communication with ourselves
about who we are which costumes we've
worn which accolades we've gotten which
ones we haven't to me the ultimate
inspiration of a human is someone who's
deck and this changes for other people
right but for me I get so inspired by
people who are really decked decorated
and have also done that that inner
healing work so they're like very pure
open and humble don't think much of
themself but then they're super
decorated so the I love that yeah so I
think of like sadguru but everyone has
their own like people that speak to them
in this way
and even mom and we Jiwon is another
great example yeah he's a king and he's
like and rooted in nature yeah yeah so
so so I love that so can you become so
one of the ultimate challenges as you
become more and more decorated with
costumes avatars accolades all these
different things can you maintain a
degree of humility and love and
compassion selflessness service can you
because if you do those two things
together are such a beautiful
expression the flowering of a human yes
it's been so many good little bits of
wisdom from this Orie
this has been really good for the
synthesis
let's make this popular
I heard that everyone make it popular
give some good action items how to do so
borsch bureau yes sir how do you feel
meaningful
uh-huh me too
I feel like I could still
and dive deep into all those feelings at
the beginning but I also am very moved
to make moves interested you know that's
that balance yes you mentioned yeah
we're not stuck in either of the play
yeah isn't it interesting how after you
brought some emotes some juicy emotion
into the field and we felt that how we
were able to riff afterward
yeah you're not stuck in either of those
polarities you live in the interval you
live in the interval you can up to a
polarity experience deeply epi' to the
other polarity experience deeply now you
can move yourself between all the
costumes between any of the energy
dynamics any athletes that anyone yeah
if you can
that's mastery yes not just one costume
but I've mastered this one cost you yes
exactly
and it's inspiring to see for people to
see that that that's real yeah
it's inspiring when we see examples of
that humble examples of that yeah yes
yeah
damn
and that X has a big role model for a
lot of
kids and adults
yes
yeah I felt that
I feel good feel really good feel live
shall we shall we wrap do we have other
thoughts that we want to share
become a life process that we are you
know we have a lot of constipated lives
happening
become a life process
constipated and muck mucky not clear but
to clear that and turns the muck in the
system in the nervous system and then
there's the muck in the web of cords
yeah that's great
that's - and by clearing the muck within
ourselves we slowly help clear the muck
in other cords Oh in our world cords
that aren't serving you can't stick
around once you start clearing your
system out because then you start
feeling the density of them so
and you have to become discerning in
your life yeah
which chords are little too mucky yeah
and which ones are clear and empowering
and that you can provide power to yeah
those were good analogies throughout
also just action items throughout just
that's a great way to move forward just
make a make a short list of a couple
people that you want to try holding
space with and go and hold space with
them and explore conversations of
knowing yourself them knowing themselves
well I that's I love that and I have a
group on Facebook that I'm just starting
off called group explorations and so
sounds good we'll put the group
explorations link also in the bio for
those that want to check it out and that
can be something that people eventually
do themselves to they can get really
good at tapping into this clearing their
own muck helping other people clear muck
and then be able to do group
explorations
that's when it gets epic that's when he
gets so epic when we share the healing
and growth process and with other humans
it's nothing richer super rich
and we evolved to be able to dive deeply
into these and in many ways they've been
obfuscated lost and off you skated so
let's remember let's bring these back
and forth all right
good hit
Wolfie brother oh my gosh look at you
future builder future builder
yeah yeah all right thanks everyone